pas que et pas que j'espère que vous
allez bien les amis c'est d'autant plus
le cas de le dire en ce moment et j'ai
envie de dire et donc j'espère j'espère
que vous allez bien et que vous êtes
prêts pour ce petit match qu'on va jouer
contre contre l'équipe
l'équipe russe ce soir contre l'équipe
russe ce soir donc on va avoir trois
matches 1 19h30 le 1 + 1 à temps et
pourquoi protéger mon truc qui part des
deux côtés ouais le 1 + 1 puis à 19h45
le 2 + 1 puis 20h55 +2 et 20h45 le
rapide le rapid moi je jouerai pas comme
les dernières fois mais je vais faire
les trois premiers matches j'espère que
vous êtes là j'espère que vous êtes
chaud j'espère que vous êtes bouillant
parce que j'ai envie de dire on a un
petit peu que ça à faire en même temps
donc il va falloir il va falloir être
fort être bouillant les rues c'est du
lourd ouais enfin bon il c'est du lourd
c'est du lourd c'est surtout du lourd
avec vladislav l'adv la daube raffin si
tu vois ce que je veux dire leur pièce
c'est peut-être pas du lourd en terme de
lots mais c'est peut-être du lourd en
terme de lourdeur quoi on sait bien
compris on sait bien compris leur pièce
on rentre on rentre directement dans le
sujet on est chaud mais il va falloir
aller aller les prendre là pour le
moment on n'a pas encore nos meilleurs
joueurs
c'est bien compris la pièce on sait bien
compris on n'a pas encore nos meilleurs
joueurs mais ils vont arriver on voit
que en haut de tableau il nous faut
quand même un peu mal mais
ouais non mais en fait ils nous font mal
partout très concrètement ils ont une
énorme équipe ans donc il va falloir se
bouger le fion les mecs est allé me
faire quelque chose pour un peu me
renforcer cette équipe
voilà on a germé on a besoin d'eux on a
besoin de gros renforts là on a besoin
on a besoin de recevoir du très très
lourd côté français il nous reste il
nous reste un gros quart d'heure parce
que c'est vrai que là en fait je suis
seul à avoir un devant en fait tu le
seul à avoir un hello on va dire plus ou
moins correct et derrière en fait ça va
être la défonce adha on a un gros un
gros gros gros déficit et ça jusqu'en
bas je crois que je vais descendre alors
ils ont encore foison de joueurs
derrière ils ont foison de joueurs mais
allez si on à poison de voir qu'ils
arrivent aussi ça peut ça peut on peut
rendre le truc un peu plus chaud quand
même du coup l efo sophos motivé là les
mecs le lien masse et là c'est la team
france un thème d'habitude
alors attendez c'est vrai qu'il est pas
rien à f j'en ai marre de choper ses
liens à je me suis un fils mais ça
marche pas alors attends attends mais
pourquoi c'est toujours la même chose on
a autre côté les gens pour qui ça marche
n'écrivent pas c'est ce qu'il faut se
dire aussi
donc ils sont censés je vais remettre le
lien de la team france c'est tout
expliqué à chaque fois il ya quand même
beaucoup de gens qui arrivent pas à non
j'ai pas j'ai pas millien de côté je
vais la récupérer c'est pas grave on
voit là faut vraiment être inscrit au
club team france et après c'est tout
bien expliquée comme il faut vous pouvez
suivre étape par étape honnêtement c'est
vraiment pas compliqué c'est plus que
faisane faisable je vous remets le lien
dans le tchat
vous avez le club et puis après vous
allez dans la dans la section live et ça
doit bien se passer pour rejoindre pour
éviter la catastrophe à dar es la
catastrophe aura évité un on à bananes
vertes qui rentrait qu'on écrive tag qui
viennent aussi peu on pourrait on
pourrait un peu parce que là en fait on
a ouais ça après tout 29 en fait on a
tous 29 qui a chaud du cachot du cal but
et là on a avoué on a triste sire après
il faut dans les forêts qui est des gens
qui viennent d'accrocher le wagon la
18,55 2000 est là devant aussi il y en a
on a un gros gap là on a un gros gap
élément n'est pas encore super nombreux
sur le live
on n'est pas encore super nombreux sur
le live j'aurais peut-être dû commencer
un peu avant en forme aujourd'hui way
plus en forme que jamais un ouais mais
les gemmes t'inquiète pas nct un je les
prends je les prends matin midi et soir
en gros vous inquiétez pas pour les gm
là on s'inquiète pas ouais ça va donc
franchement de braves ça va hein
ethan franchement franchement c'est de
l'eau tu le prends d'oberhof tu le
prends tu l'heure tourne bim bim je
dirais tu vas pas avoir peur de nos
braves quand même la nuit ne confère pas
les inscriptions à l'est la nina adriana
allez on bouge
allez moi je vais faire je vais faire
mon philippe et de cheney cela qu'est ce
que c'est là yahia il ya 3 il ya trois
inscriptions à accepter allez allez
l'admin planète mines l'admin l'admin on
n'est pas beaucoup et non n'est pas on
n'est pas énorme sur sur le live ce soir
tout le monde peut jouer seul n 14 mais
tout le monde peut jouer
l'admin l'a admis la demie l'admin allez
on te veulent admin c'est moi qui
essayent de nous ramener du monde elle
il faut faut y aller la saluer les frais
de la chambre plat chaud plat il ya une
équipe ya 7 de baisse qui est là ça y
est ça commence ça commence à rentrer là
ça commence à rentrer année ça commence
à rentrer de leur côté aussi franchement
franchement les mangin banane verte
je pense que franchement faut pas que
vous ne faut pas que tes peurs pantera
fatalis là faut pas avoir peur hein
d'oberhof de bref tu rentres dans l'aria
plus rien c'est rien du tout les amiens
c'est rien du tout les amis c'est rien
du tout faux-pas à faut pas avoir peur
là devant are you il va manger sharma de
canal les nuls il est nul les amis il
est nu lario il va le manger
- hubert je le prends je vais je vais
lui faire un jeu lui faire un double
contact
il va plus voir le ballon cette baisse
il va attaquer comme un malade
ouais non mais on est très très bien on
est très très bien les amis on est très
très bien regardez regardez il ya du
monde qui rentre là il ya masure hameau
il n'était pas là il ya tous les regards
regardez-moi à l'aller les 2100 comment
vous allez aimer manger la syrie loup
69,6 va regarder encore ça monte encore
devant sa rente de partout ça rentre de
partout vous allez aimer manger on va en
faire du porche les amis ça va être du
porche triste sire il joue contre rosa
idriss ova il va il va il va en faire de
la bouillie cccc chaussée chose c'est
chaud ça rentre de partout ça rentre de
partout les amis notre équipe est solide
notre équipe est solide il horizons plus
nombreux que nous ils sont plus nombreux
que nous mais pas pas tant que ça que ça
hein
ils sont ils sont de plus on dit ça joue
plus on réussit aux échecs en france
ouais t'as deux fois plus d'habitants il
ya deux mecs de plus sur le truc il se
passe quoi là vous êtes en quarantaine
vous êtes tous là les mecs on l'a par
contre l'année voilà ouais on est plus
nombreux qu'eux on est plus nombreux les
amis les français jouent plus aux échecs
que les ruses et c'est la vérité les
amis et c'est la vérité les amis on est
en train de le prouver les amis on est
en train de le prouver
on est là les amis on m'a dit la russie
c'est le pays des échecs rien du tout la
france les amis la france mais bien sûr
les amis palmarès des candidats maxime
vachier lagrave est plus fort que les
trois russes c'est tous les amis c'est
tout les français sont au dessus voilà
c'est prouvé on nous sommes plus
nombreux on a encore des joueurs qui
rentrent il faudrait des forfaits la
côté russe
il faut les mettre forfait côté russe
les amis on veut des points gratuits on
veut des points gratuits
on m'a dit c'est un grand pays c'est un
grand pays si tu compare à des petits
pays
là tu te compare à la france c'est un
petit pays voilà les français sont là
voilà on est là les mecs et on est plus
nombreux qu'eux et on va aller manger
tout cru du boeuf strogonoff les amis on
va le manger le boeuf strogonoff on va
le manger de partout sur tous les
terrains là allez on y rentre on va
rentrer de partout ils vont essayer de
ramener des grands maîtres pour se
battre contre nous ils vont avoir du mal
ils vont avoir du mal on rentre de
partout où elle est continuer à vous
inscrire j'ai entendu dire je les
entends dire déroulé de façon si s'il ya
quelqu'un qui badauds bref vous savez ce
qui va se passer
attention les amis ou excusez moi je les
battues dos ça peut piquer en bon on
verra où pourquoi du bullet aujourd'hui
va ça commence toujours par du bulletin
où j'ai battu donnant à fond mais on va
y aller on va les manger les amis
attention aux petits mails sur les
forums on ne sait pas comment ai je fait
pour perdre une partie alors un peu
attention on sépare sait pas trop sur
quelle base ils portent ou quoi mais bon
ca
qui est bien connu dans le milieu pour
accuser un peu tous les gens qui le bat
donc automatiquement
automatiquement on est au courant mais
on va aller manger les amis c'est pas ça
le problème c'est pas ça le problème
allez on continue à rentrer monsieur
patate monsieur patate il va leur mettre
une patate de forain les amis il va leur
mettre une patate de forain est ce qu'on
peut jouer à partir l'année d'appui par
smartphone je crois pas alex quoique pas
encore quand un fait ici je sais pas si
je vais gagner
non mais toi tu peux gagner joue contre
jacob galère mais banane verte
attention tu joues contre l'auto
proclamé meilleur joueur du monde mais
vous rappeler comment nacala pétrole
il avait trois la faune pendant le match
n'était parti pendant le truc et où il
n'est pas très aisé mais on va dire ça
comme ça si tu fais les choses un peu
moche mais très fort dans les title
tuesday donc là peut rien dire donc mais
on est on est beaucoup plus droit je
suis désolé les mecs mohammadi la russie
c'est un pays déchets que je vous ai dit
venez nombreux bon apparemment je me
suis trompé je me suis trompé il ya
pierre cap hier qu'à 89 jeff 85 je sais
pas si vous allez jouer les mecs un
yatch à ria le frigo bruiteur on ne sait
pas il ya vérité 54 vérité 54 il sait
pas s'il va jouer quoi est-ce qu'on peut
jouer depuis la puce atom sont en ville
et je crois pas c'est mr mahmoud ammar
todorov ouais ouais c'est légal des
malades de corning oeil silva écoute moi
j'ai deux modo le pion d'à côté qui ont
le corona quoi je suis dégoûté deux
démos de blitz crimes sont atteints par
le coronale c'est une information de
première main que je vous donne donc
c'est un peu la rs enfin combien combien
restera-t-il de modo à la fin de la fin
à la fin de l'épidémie quoi moi non
c'est vrai vrai ouais ouais c'est pas
assez pas du troll c'est pas du troll
vrai non non non non on a on a vraiment
deux mots dont on a deux modo atteint du
corona donc on est quand même à très
touché non mais vraiment plus en moi je
suis vraiment calfeutrée chez moi c'est
hikaru c'est hikaru c'est sûr prenez
soin de vous les rails vraiment
prenez soin de vous brassart est chaud
ludovic pas encore mais j'ai peur que
ludique soit bientôt atteint bas pour le
moment il se porte bien enfin ils sont
ils ont de la fièvre et ils sont en
sueur mais pour le moment ils sont ils
n'ont pas les complications quoi je joue
j'espère vraiment qu'ils aient pas de
complications pour la peine ça me ferait
mal de voir des règles comme ça tombait
quoi tomber au combat
franchement ça peut ça peut être relou
attention match bull est de +1 qui
commande de suite après t'inquiète pas
adrian chamond et sur le coup moi ce que
je te demande adrian schaming en tant
qu'administrateur du groupe cdh à
accepter les règles si tu vois là il ya
beaucoup de règles qui sont venus pour
pour jouer le match on est chauds faut
accepter niveau admin faut bouger ce que
jette alors je suis un peu un philippe
etchebest l'as tu veux faut envoyer les
assiettes la forme envoyer les assiettes
là là on en voit on en voit on en voit
on n'en voit pas ce que la la ça va plus
ouais pas que ce soit pour faire penser
à autre chose mais bon tu vois il ya des
gens de la commune qui sont touchées on
pense à eux quand même tu vois j'ai
envie de dire on est quand même une
communauté quoi on les mange derrière
ouais on l'est si tu veux cost mais ça
peut être un peu faim fait quand même
attention à ce que tu dis mais ouais
mais on est tellement plus nombreux la
[ __ ] de russie en sueur face à la
france mais amenez moi une équipe
amenez moi une équipe les amis iam non
non je sais pas je suis comprend pas en
fait tu vois ça tu te dis ccg recalés la
place de la france dans le monde dira
que fait poutine que fait poutine
poutine doit venir régler ça c'est pas
normal mais c'est parce qu'ils ont de
nombreux leaders donc peut-être que
c'est vrai
du coup les mecs boycott peut-être un
peu le match et il ya cristal qui est
rentré et il ya cryptage qui vient de
rentrer dans l'équipe les amis ya
cryptage qui est la crypte ali va le
manger degroof
il va le manger tout cru il va l'écraser
les amis il va faire de la purée
d'aubrac ce sera plus vlad d'oberhof se
sera pure et d'oberhof les amis il sera
écrasée il va être écrasé crypte à lille
va il va il va en faire il va il va en
faire un couscous les amis
il va en faire un vrai couscous et
l'autre chaise qui vient d'être acceptée
est allé loach est ce tu vas venir aussi
mais bien sûr mais bien sûr les amis et
salut pour le pin à tort pour le pin à
tort ma copine et russes donc pas le
droit de perdre ma femme est française
maintenant voilà il faut le savoir ça se
passe mieux en moins de 30 secondes mais
dc bien adrian shamim a sorti une belle
assiette
il m'a sorti locke chess le monstre du
loch ness va venir nous aider non mais
bon à bout d'un moment
non mais il faudra vraiment des points
bonus un mois je vais écrire à thiès
comme jordi refiler nous des bonus si
les noues du fric quoi c'est à dire une
nous file du fric juste parce qu'on est
plus on re quoi pour toute la commune
ont fait des désabonnements diamant jeu
parce qu'on fait on est tellement plus
que adrian cham les amis adrian chagny
va jouer contre le docteur timofey le
docteur timofeyeva être en masque allez
tu va le manger mon derrière franchement
les mecs c'est chaud à vous accrocher 1
50 points elo sais rien vous leur
rentrée dans l'art est là derrière faut
me faire les points l'américain a les
big band tout le monde vous êtes chauds
et devant vous inquiétez pas on s'en
occupe on s'en occupe pareil banane
c'est un sérieux on n'est pas si loin
franchement quand points à rioz à 2240 y
va franchement sharma de canal je le
connais are you i va le manger et
panthère afata glisse il est trop chaud
bah nan nan franchement c'est bon
franchement c'est bon on va les
assaisonner ouais on va les assaisonner
on est bien on est bien
on a coco l'asticot qui rentrent merlin
merlin l'enchanteur coastal asticote
même merlin l'enchanteur dans el fahm au
zoo camelot coco l'asticot on est
tellement bien on est tellement bien ça
commence donc quatre minutes ça commence
dans quatre minutes et on est on a une
[ __ ] d'equipe là les mecs
franchement on peut le faire si tu quand
je me rappelle du premier match contre
l'iran c'était chaud et quand je vois
l'équipe qu'on a aujourd'hui c'est une
dream team c'est à dire que là c'est
extraordinaire c'est extraordinaire ils
sont ils sont un poil plus fort mais bon
comme disait c'est vraiment injuste de
ne pas avoir une vingtaine de points
cadeaux l'algérie parmi nous à une
personne en face ils ont personnes ils
ont personnes c'est quand même pas
normal
veronica chess par contre à licques si
tu chopes le 0 6 1 alik cité dans chat
escale x et dans le tchat
veronica de chasse faut me choper faut
me choper les 0-6 tonton 1
il est où il est où le temps dont on me
choper le verrou 6 1 veronica de chasse
at a une mission c'est max grossman et
de master l'équivalent or la mission tu
étais sur arte sur une mission la tonte
en censurant à ses loques lu au monde
entier sur l'émission attention hein
mais il falloir il va falloir faire le
tapin les mecs c'est pas que des échecs
il va falloir faire le taf devant n'est
quand même pas mal on est pas mal ils
ont essayé de ramener des titres est là
pour faire les malins mais vous
inquiétez pas on est plus fort par
exemple quand je vois tout je suis
surpris que ça de voir ça commence par
les 40 plus rapide et c'est mieux en
fait parce que du coup ceux qui veulent
jouer les rapides qui sont plus forts
généralement ils jouent les premiers
matches et puis après il se bat c'est
plus cool et salue ce stage chez elle
qu'elle est à chier tu te dépêches tu
rentres à l'esta tchèque qui ronflait
mais qui va faire la différence d'un
chèque vous avez trouvé l'installer
rockin veronica chess marrant sérieux no
fake non arrêter les mecs c'est
tellement l'élite de la nation on est
tellement élitiste
s'ils arrêtent et moi ça les mecs ont
trouvé un installa non arrêtez arrêtez
moi ça est ce qu'ils sont aussi doués
que ça je peux pas y croire je checke
tout de suite sur mon téléphone
à tel point qu à tel point que c'est
l'élite de la nation ils peuvent ils
peuvent l'avoir fait on va voir si
sérieux c'est un vrai instinct arrête
c'est vous êtes vraiment l'élite [ __ ]
l'aller je m'abonne vous êtes vraiment
l'élite
c'est impossible d'être aussi élitiste
que c'est que ce chat en fait c'est
vraiment un vrai un stack quoique non
mais franchement ce qui a mis l'instant
j'ai retrouvé ça qui est le génie
alfredo la chanteuse a déjà rien comme
ceux d'autres façons savais que c'était
l'élite de la nation
mais là si tu veux tu étais j'ai envie
de te voir un culte quoi by fred en
lâchant que là j'ai envie de le mettre
modo suis pas ce mot sur big three mal
fait trois matches là quoi c'est c'est
obliger ses lacets c'est lâchant que la
divine quoi c'est a été a été oh [ __ ]
mais qu il était fort qu il était fort
attrait de la chante la haye l'a été il
a été assez un vrai tonton les mecs ça
j'ai envie de chialer tellement il était
fort moi j'ai envie de chialer lennik
parle franchement bravo a franchement
pas assez pour des gens comme ça tu vois
qu'on fait des stream taille et il est
très très fort il est très très fort en
fait il y avait le pseudo de veronica
ceschi et 550 sur sûr
surtout chasse comme et le mec nous amis
dont le tchad sont instagram quoi et
donc là franchement le mec qui fait ça
sur un chat which tu vois le niveau de
réactivité passé 1
c'est un grand quoi c'est un grand
monsieur c'est c'est un grand monsieur
du chat cdu c'est du jamais vu quoi je m
ça comme ça je vais enlever
je vais garder le score du match en
dessous pour que vous puissiez à mais on
va pas avoir le score bon du coup on a
enlevé le score on va mettre ça comme ça
allez ça ça démarre sa des marins ou
dandysme et à l'eni focus haullard naya
silva rabot qu'emi aussi aller s'il m'en
allais sylvain mais nous les points via
silva qui rentrait dans l'équipe les
amis on va les taper les amis allez
allez on y va
zuber aller il ya presque hubert dans le
nom ça va ça va bien se passer ou là il
voue une hollandaise qui jouent ils
jouent comme son ami de rohff ou plutôt
est ce que j'ai pas trop peur de gagner
on ne sait pas on ne sait pas
c'est ça satam eu deux cavalières vii
bouffe f6 attend alors ça puisque le
pouf pas une fois la bouffe ici je
connais pas je connais pas je connais
pas par adama 5-fu d2 à saddam b6 je
convoque ya peut-être faire tourbe et 8
des 5
que je joue plus vite je vais prendre
une fois je suis je joue trop lentement
là avec le fonds 3 j'ai pris trop de
temps roi b1
je suis pas je suis pas sûr la cadence
là allez allez je me réveille je
m'attaque fondé 4 1
je vais faire f3 g4 je suis pas sûr sûr
de mon truc h 4h 5h 6h g5 du coup le
fourrage 3 pour rentrer en aussi ce
jeune champion h cinq sages et oublier
évidemment tu très mal les mecs je suis
très très mal là je suis ni
charismatique niveau quoi je pas trop le
choix je me paraît que le roi je suis
dans la demeure totale j'étais pas
acheter pas chaud pour la cadence en
vrai
j'étais pas chaud pour la cadence et
schwytz ouais elle doit être perdu ça là
ok je suis déçu film i'm a trick est
dans l'ouverture mais j'ai une mauvaise
position
bon allez j'essaye de me remonter mal
joué ça arrive ça arrive ça arrive mais
c'est de faire mieux dans la deuxième il
faut je remonte au score la halle et
j'en vois de l'autre côté à les gens
voient à fond même c'est pas très bon je
vous vite mais c'est très mauvais c'est
donc en que j'ai pas fait de bullet je
souffre watts un peu quand une tour ans
et 8 qui a aidé catch verger 6
ouais je vais faire c'est cinq cavaliers
aussi ce que je chatte ce cavale faut
que je le dégage
et s'il faut faire option pense que de
bonne augure à l'hercules je vais fermer
cette diagonale peut-être pas mal à ce
que je viens de jouer et j'ai tâté des
cinq essais 3 met une tour en des huit
qui avaient des cinq essais 3 je vais
mettre à tour ans et it
il va être échangé une fois que je nom
de la tour en des 8 mai c'est qu'on
s'est mal joué c'est certainement mal
joué ouais
je suis fait avoir j'avais pas vu je
fais refuge et 5 intermédiaire mais il
ya ça et ça marche pas du tout je tente
devant sortir comme je peux mais je suis
trop my joy à la pendule et je me suis
bien battu mais ça suffit pas bon alors
à temps et l'âme des six
j'ai encore un petit peu de jeu quand
même
il a été bon là
haye adam programme
je suis idiot mais bon elles perdent et
de façon la finale as à perdre est bon
il a été meilleur que moi il a été très
bon bullet on se fait défoncer on s'est
fait manger au score il est bon en
bullet c'est très bon village et enfin
j'ai pas mal réussi mais là lui il a été
très bon et on a trop de retard et l'eau
partout bon on a perdu une bataille ne
va pas forcément perdre la guerre
prochain match à 19 45 est lé maillon
faible et j'avais fait cet ennemi sur
huit et là j'en ai perdu 2 mais bon ça
change pas grand chose
gt gt pas chaud j'étais pas chauve c'est
parti je me suis bien battu mais je n'ai
pas réussi à me prend ses cinq prises
ces vies qui va faire des quatre pouces
et trois poupées cap des cinq des six il
était toujours devant
bah ils sont chauds les rousses coffre
mais bon après on est tellement plus
nombreux nouvelle fois on devrait bon
mais même avec les points bonus on
n'aurait pas gagné mais ils sont chauds
soit 167 à 103 104 à 170 soit on s'est
fait on s'est fait bouffer les mecs ils
ont vraiment une équipe de ouf un bon
allez on se lasse pas
4 on gagne le deuxième match aller on
revient à un partout là on a perdu un
match n'a pas perdu la guerre
jean luc cayez les oreilles mais je vois
qu'il ya des gens qui ont réussi à
mettre les points mais malheureusement
pierre pierre qui a perdu 2 0 contre
aironi catch est quoi donc le prochain
match il est vraiment dans la foulée 1-1
je vais rejouer donc le même gars il m'a
vraiment bien dominé savoir si je vais
un peu regardé son son pedigree une
chaîne twitch attention
selon elles les bombes il est trahi et
passives ont un bon ben je suis plus
fort que lui mais bon après si je joue
beaucoup en bullet c'est vrai que ça
donne une habitude
ouais il fait que des bulles est fier
que des bullet mais moi j'en fais plus
du tout mais forcément ça aide
ouais super league 2 0 mais bon les
bullet ce pull est c'est le bullet un
allez on se ressaisit
on est sur le deuxième match aller on
peut on peut le faire les mecs on peut
le faire
déjà la daube rohff qui séparait pas ce
qu'il doit dire ça triche en face c'est
sûr ça qui séparait de bras fin on voit
pas wade a dû dire et ça a triché en
face il a fait quoi de bronze au premier
match bon je sais pas où on en est pour
voir le premier match il ya moins
d'écart ce prochain match
ouais je pense qu'en beats on va les
bouffer en beach je pense qu'on va les
bouffer en vrai on va voir en tout cas
ce qu on est plus nombreux que sur le
deuxième match
c'est surtout en milieu de tableau qui
font la différence
l'un d'eux plus joué en bullet que nous
ils n'avaient plus à mais bon c'est du 2
+ 1 on peut les plus nombreux on est
prêt c'est vraiment c'est gérant par la
pièce comme un ça devrait ça devrait
avoir une valeur aurait pu à 15h
ralentir plus l'écart va traduire bas
puis ça ressemble à des échecs l'on sera
fort en fait à deux bras fils est revenu
à année il s'est mis troisième hello i'm
et c'est bien ce que je disais il a
perdu d'oberhof c'est bien ce que je
disais il a dû perdre non non il a gagné
2 0 à sa fiche à rocky a pas réussi à
lui prendre un pot a fait chier à
l'aisselle fiche arolla faut revenir
voilà sinon de façon sylvain il va le
bouffer d'europe pas d'os comme un souci
faut qu'ils reviennent la french are aud
ok reviennent on a besoin lui la mémoire
toujours moins forts en bulles est que
zuber quoi et je me sens pas dans la
forme optimale pour jouer mais bon on va
faire ce qu'on peut les niveaux rien de
points en une grosse volonté
j'étais contraint 1100 je suis contraint
1500 maintenant ouais c'est peut-être
nous qui sommes moins nombreux pour le
deuxième match et pas c'est peut-être
nous qui sommes moins nombreux plus tôt
allez les mecs sains faut s'inscrire là
pour le deuxième match info faut rentrer
un faut rentrer dedans les mecs sains
non là on va se faire bouffer on à
nouveau 200 points de retard de partout
bon allez on part pas défaitiste on se
bat les mecs
allez je vais essayer de donner
l'exemple je vais mettre les point les
mecs vraiment que vous ressentiez les
mecs devant sortait la boîte à claques
voilà c'est ça
ils sont 150 millions est pour le moment
on en reparle dans trois mois on en
reparle dans trois mois des populations
par pays
freddy mambo un freddy bamboo pour le
moment ils sont 160 150 millions donc
d'humour noir mais il faut bien un peu
d'humour dans cette situation du chat
[ __ ] ou on va faire quoi on va pleurer
on va chialer
on allume la télé tu fais que chialer
tuchel du loup retrouve twitter tu
cherches du lourd
tu fais que chalet du lourd parce que
parce que parce que parce que la
situation est grave mais là on est là
pour un peu rigoler je suis là pour
faire penser un peu à autre chose les
amis voilà pour qu'on ait un peu le tu
vois tu as un peu un peu le bonheur de
vivre et que voilà qu'on retouche qu'on
retrouve une touche d'humour une touche
de gaieté suis acheté un petit peu le
rayon de soleil de votre journée quoi tu
as they are que tu avais pas le soleil
parce qu'il y avait des nuages le soleil
est arrivé et il est il épaule il a posé
les couilles sur ce stream tu vois ce
que j'ai envie de te dire c'est à deux
grosses couilles sur le stream c'est le
soleil quoi tu vois il envoie des rayons
c'est cvg tu as tu vois asif sais tu as
et dragon ball quoi c'est dragon ball
bon allez on l'état pour l'aider fond si
y'en a marre il nous manque un gala qui
a quitté pleut c'est un belge pleutre
revient à notre ami belge
tu étais venu aider la francophonie les
amis revient revient à l'est les amis
allez on les bat on les bat pour les bat
on est bouillant me refaire son
hollandaise de merde et je sais toujours
pas quoi faire mais il avait l'air de
connaître la théorie studio tête du feu
4h commence avec les noirs j'en ai marre
de cette variante insipide au possible
mais bon c'est pas mal pour le bullet
moi je fais semi n'importe quoi au moins
ça me change pas de la partie précédente
c'est déjà le point positif
bon alors peut-être le pion détroit qui
peut être un peu vulnérable os bada
mambé si soudée qu'adam ses sept mois
1,6 g s'est tapé sur détroit et ce qui
peut le défendre des 3 je crois qu'il
peut pas aller on a un peu plus de temps
donc forcément ça favorise les joueurs
plus forts aux échecs et ça fait déjà un
peu light faille je vais prendre le pion
je vais mettre le cavalier ans et 7
il va faire froid et faim je faire dame
ces deux jeux prendre une fois ici je
prends une fois ici et j'allais jouer la
colonne à grâce à mon cavalier aller
colonna on parle pas du vent les blagues
en le niveau de l'humour
allez tour ici tour à 2
et b5 merde ça j'ai oublié les mains et
qui a été quatre qui va arriver
j'ai fait la faute
je suis à foot est roi
jamais je le mette ans et 6 quand même
et je vais essayer de ramener le roi
rockets
j'ai foncé 4
ok je râle un peu le roi
parce que je faire des quatre mais je
prends trop temps en fait j'essaye de
jouer aux échecs normand j'ai pas le
peps ce soir carrier prend j'ai
peut-être faire non je faire cavalier
que reprend et je vais [ __ ] en d3
c'est bien joué je pense que je fais ce
que je vais attaquer f2 et j'attaque b4
aussi
et je vais prendre et je vais prendre b4
mais je parle à gagner je pense quoi que
je sais pas
alliant des 5
je fais un mur pour le roi en fait
c'était l'idée j'essaie de pousser mais
je me sens pas à l'aise quand le design
après je domine 1
ouais c'est malheureux mais c'est nul
ils proposent n'y aura jamais un [ __ ]
il va la forcer comme ça au caire avec
un peu plus de temps je la gagne est
dommage
puis j'ai vraiment dominé mais a j'étais
fébrile en finale aller
mais ça je connaissais le courant plus
juste un problème de mémoire je me
rappelle plus
c'est juste un problème de mémoire je
connaissais je me rappelle plus mais
c'est peut-être prendre à me prendre
quatre quoi qu'il en soit d'ailleurs
quel jeu les espions
je vais faire cavaler f3 je jouais le
développement x 6 3 ab 1 fera en p1 de
façon il va me coller un échec un jour
je lui colle un pion h4 un pion h5 est
un pion h6 il va faire rock h55
mais j'aurai dame c4 dont croquage 5 8 h
6 ouais ça va c'est cool il n'a pas trop
de casse pour ces pour ses pièces
je vais faire des six intermédiaire
annoncé qu'on jeu par kate et quatre
intermédiaires comme ça je veux qu'à
relief 5 et je couvre les maths amis
peut quand même joué f5 prise il ya des
quatre qui restent en l'air et l'eau qui
était 5e f 5 je fais d'am dam des trois
mais j'ai oublié qu'il avait tardé à
retirer des f4 et maintenant je suis
plus mieux et maintenant je suis plus
mieux il va prendre ici je dois
reprendre une fois il va prendre je vais
faire ces trois pour éviter tous les
problèmes mais j'ai pourri mon avantage
c'est le champion h6 les gens mettent à
angers 4 allez on va la jouer à la
minute par la masculine est une
tourangelle 1 pour aller bouffer ça
j'aime est un fou en d3 fr ou 5 je vais
faire tout rejet 7 mai aura le temps de
faire 4 ok si je fais ton j'ai un équidé
sur fion prend dame prend et à les mater
ok allez sur fou prend il peut reprendre
c'est ouf non je me fais contre matt et
là bas je suis deg à je suis sûr que
j'étais gagnant je suis sûr que j'avais
un gain non j'étais pas loin j'ai pas
été bon j'ai pas été bon j'aurais dû la
gagner les amis j'aurais dû la gagner
les amis c'est tellement pas loin
d'avoir quelque chose aurait dû tenter
pour le cadre d'un projet café ça fait
quand même mais bon bref cinq dames g5
un g6 serait n'était pas loin où on
s'est fait défoncer dans le match on
s'est fait croquer
on s'est fait croquer les amis
ouais on s'est fait croquer sylvain est
là on s'est fait on s'est fait manger on
s'est fait on n'a pas existé les amis
heureusement que d'oberhof n'est pas
dans notre équipe un sinon sans reparler
j'aurais vraiment pu faire quelque chose
dans cette game j'étais vraiment pas si
mal dans la game
c'est là que j'étais bien je faire
justin comme dames 1 anticipé la merde
la préférence 115 6
je sens que j'ai pas là j'ai pas le mode
aujourd'hui première jouer vous voyez
pas vous voyez pas le chéquier part à
manger enlever le truc bon et buzz qui a
gagné 2 0 voilà il nous reste un match
plein pour moi il reste un match dans
six minutes allait jouer contre
d'oberhof alors soit je le crois les
abandonne pour me foutent de sa gueule
je joue pas contre toi je ne te
respectent pas ou alors je le bats bien
envie tu parles à respecter quand même
j'hésite
enfin abandonner ce qui est le plus gros
foutage de gueule qui existe
à voir on va voir je vais essayer de le
battre mais bon il est formé dans notre
quotidien ils nous foutent de sa gueule
aussi calme j'hésite
déjà je pourrais le bloquer peut-être je
peut l'interdire
bon on va rond on va on va voir mais oui
super en fait j'ai senti que je le
dominais était surtout ambulatoire est
là on voit que 26 77
bon bah on va voir on va on va essayer
on est vraiment une grosse différence
est là mais la réussite est sûr que ce
sera un match difficile un allez faut
s'inscrire les mecs info faut venir nous
aider quand même la série love qui est
là allez série d'offres pour omettre les
points ça va être dur quand même
pour le tournoi il faut cliquer ici
donc ils sont plus nombreux que nous
pour le moment dans cette cadence allez
les mecs on s'inscrit font rentrer dans
le match aller non un remake d'un chat
de brefs mais elle mérite même pas qu'on
parle de lui en vrai
en vrai il mérita ils méritent même pas
que l'on qu'on prononce son nom en fait
je pense c'est mérité mérite même pas
comprendre a les bons peut on peut les
prendre on peut les prendre
donc allez on se bat on essaie en fait
on essaye voilà on est ronde ou quoi on
fait environ suit le conseil de mur tu
as joué une partie allez on suit ce
conseil jouer une partie on joue une
partie quoi on vous tous une partie
mais quand même comme ya trop de gens
qui a qui demande il a fait quoi
en fait je le bats en du jour et une
robe bleue défonce et réactions il écrit
il écrit des lettres à thiès comme pour
me faire bannir mon compte tu vois alors
que je bossais déjà pour thiès comme on
l'a pas de chance pour lui parce que
comme j'étais en train de stream est bon
bah il y avait en plus la vidéo mais
c'est quand même c'est quand même un peu
abusé quoi ce qu'elle est un peu avisés
c'est quand même un peu avisé
heureusement que j'avais le heureusement
que j'avais le truc quoi donc
non mais c'était ce test était une
grotte où j'avais eu beaucoup de chance
en fait mais bon
chance j'étais mal toute la pas très
bien toute la partie et puis après il se
trouve que je les embrouilles et que
j'ai gagné mais bon de là à les faire
une lettre un machin à jazz comme et
tout bon faut quand même raison garder a
accepté la défaite quoi mais c'est
surtout parce que je débarque avec une
robe c'est surtout parce que j'ai eu une
grotte et du coup ça l'a fait rager mais
oui pendant un atelier c'est une
accusation comme ça machin il devrait
être accusé ni devrait devrait être
sanctionné ouais c'est faux fouet c'est
un petit peu abusé quoi surtout que la
partie n est pas extraordinaire
c'était dans un tournoi reiss était dans
un title tuesday mais par contre lui
quand il gagne des title tuesday parce
que je crois qu on m a gagné déjà deux
étaient très forts là aucun doute n'est
permis
là aucun doute n'est permis c'est à dire
que moi je finis j'avais peut-être fini
que 50e de staple tous des bons il faut
bannir à mon compte par contre lui gagné
deux fois le title tuesday c'est bien il
n'y a pas de doute idée 24,81 fille d'un
tu vois j'ai envie de dire les échos
donc ça ça m'avait un petit peu salée
bon peu importe mais pas là pour parler
de ça je le faire des 4 on va essayer de
le battre quand même normal on y joue
cavalier f6 va quand même essayer de
gagner
on va jouer au 6e 4 h 6 vous prend et
ses trois élus une variante dont il va
il change variante on va voir ce qu'il
fait froid jusqu'à de tempo bien
évidemment mais qui va jouer là bas noir
avec g 5 g h et trois bombes à la fois
ça peut être facile je pourrai dire à
peut-être qu'ils regardent sur une base
de données pendant la partie fatiha
c'est très facile d'accuser les gens
sans preuve
tu peux accuser de tout dernièrement
ouais c'est pas parler de ça ce corps et
il joue la meilleure variante mais fin
joueur c'est normal il est grand maître
et puis de toute façon c'est pas c'est
pas une information secrète un
énormément de gens qui le savent mais
pourquoi réfléchit-il au cinquième coupe
au 6e tour on ne sait pas bon non mais
je vous normalement mais c'est juste
pour dire c'est vraiment très facile
bon pour la peine il réfléchit vraiment
longtemps donc il se rappelle plus à
partir de maintenant ce qui est une
bonne nouvelle
ce qui est une bonne nouvelle pour voir
comment ça évolue
on a un petit drapeau français à côté du
pseudo ça fait plein je pense que vous
l'avez tous dans le match alors qu'elle
sait si son affaire keller 3 tempo lui
faire croire que c'est eric jordan b6 et
kaïs et 3 je pense x 6,3 f2 ça va
transposer mais peut-être j'ai le temps
de faire des cinq intermédiaire du coup
maintenant à défendre l'option d'une
autre manière ce qu'ils étaient
ac ont en tout cas c'est sûr qu'ils se
rappellent pas la position est bizarre
et les pions doublé de partout
est ce que l'échangé là mais si cons
quant à son prix je peux faire damas
cinq échecs dans cui faire des 5 et 5 et
prend pions prends je te fait refouler
cinq échecs reprend 17 ou non peut-être
qualifiée 3 et d'un mach 5 rapidos à
quoi que je faire téléprompteur prendre
un match 5 dame décide d'un projet 5 et
je défends b2 mais surtout g7 du coup
cavaliers c3 est peut-être allé jouer
pour le grand roque avec une position
très bizarre bon je sais qu'il n'aime
pas trop les trucs très chaotique
il est bon dedans mais quand ils se
considèrent comme plus fort il préfère
veut des trucs plus simple du coup sûr
qu'à radio 5 on va prendre des frères
d'armes h5 tempo g7 et c3
je pense ça peut le faire et de faire un
petit en plus et là dessus je voulais
faire d'en prendre cinq à six dames c3
c'est quoi le problème
parce que je défends là quand même
m6 dame c3 et je veux qu'elle ait des
deux cas et c'est 4
clairement il a calculé moins loin que
moi et - bien sûr tout fait tout rejet 8
d'accor 1 mais il veut fou g7
ce qui est loin d'être con ok donc en
fait il a vu loin ok je faire dame ces
trois fous j'ai 7 e 5 dames c'est cette
quête des 2.5
fourbe et cinq échecs
les pleutres à
ça c'est pleutre mais bouffe l'autre
mais cependant bien joué
je trouvais ce moment assez bien joué en
réalité
il a bien eus
y a rien à dire c'est bien joué on
faisait 4 faites sur sa chemisette est
fait cavaler f3
ok là tu veux les faire cavalier f3
peut-être trouvé cinq échecs c'était
pâques ou intermédiaire ok mais surtout
prendre froid je ferais foulée 5 à
chaque intermédiaire à ce moment là qui
n'est pas content mais j'ai quand même
pris une minute trente sur le match mais
s'est engagé avec qui etc ont nulle part
je vais le faire maintenant ce que j'ai
quand même l'impression que met son roi
sur d8 c'est pas idiot mais maintenant
on fait je sais pas comment continuer
quels furent le coup le plus bizarre du
monde
je pense que j'avais besoin de cette
tour pour défendre un peu tout essayé de
faire qui a aidé quatre par la suite est
toute l'idée dormir au hand évite aussi
c'est que l'option f7 peut être attaqué
pas dire qu'il ya plein de raisons pour
laquelle je vous l'empêchez grand roque
aussi ils seront dix-huit comme peut
être moi même je suis pas sûr que j'ai
raison 1
donc voilà je vais essayer de faire
qu'il y ait des 4 je pense même surtout
ses cinq filles étaient quatre et tant
pis pour les pions double est ok je vais
lui carrément des cats c'est sûr que je
veux pour preuve cette mégère food et 3
une fois f5 quand même sur kébé 5 en
réserve pour échanger le fou en cas de
besoin il se barre
ah ouais j'aurais dû le prendre ce fou
j'ai mal joué
mauvais jugement à ça peut être une
erreur décisive
je vais prendre une fois il va prendre
de la touche verte et f5 pour tenir à la
case h4
sur un tour f4 et je vais être cette
tour en d1
feige des six
bien joué
j'ai quand même faire des six a non mais
je peux pas faire cavalier prend mais
non j'ai gaffé
il ya vous prend 2,3 sur échec c'est sûr
échec j'ai gaffé
dresser une partie vraiment complexe 1
il a contre gaffes et là la fourchette
c'est une partie jusque complexe et
c'est normal que les deux joueurs gaffe
bon après il va peut-être m'accuser de
tout et de rien on ne sépare amer mais
il a contre gaffé il faut dire il y
avait beaucoup de tactique partout mal
élevés
jouer comme ça
j'ai essayé de faire ça
vous voyez mon pions
je suis chopé sa [ __ ] je prends 10 6
je suis proche peut prendre ok
tous ces trois rois prend 1,3 en fait et
on apprend à deux tours pensée 3
toujours
ok on va le faire tour ces deux je
protège tous les rouages et 4 pas proche
300 habitants de bolt est nul dans tout
les cas danse je te prends dans tout les
cas danse je te prends tellement tu es
nul
oui petit oui petit oui petit j'ai
encore montré qui était le patron sur
encore montré il doit être en train de
chialer ona en train de chialer le ce
nul
ce nul les amis fait très attention il a
été mauvais les amis il s'est fait
dominer il s'est fait prendre en vous
savez comment les amis elle a fait
plaisir celle là elle a fait plaisir les
amis elle a fait super plaisir
elle a fait super plaisir et même dans
la finale comme en juillet tout mi
juillet toumi les amis j'ai déchargé les
amis il a existe plus en a par contre
j'ai pas trop la théorie je retrouve
souvent mal dans cette variante
ouais je reçois un mail de chess comme
là c'est sûr
gaza un fait plaisir de le taper mais
quand même 2009 sur czech comme il pas
bon il est mauvais mais il peut il peut
quand même faire quelques trucs parfois
je vais prendre une fois
j'en ai offerts le parados de salle g 6
g ultra bizarre mais je me dis peut-être
un jour mon fouillis revient en g7 et je
veux faire f 5 4
en tout cas belle victoire des
américains
je suis très mal sorti l'ouverture oula
ça marche pas du tout je fais n'importe
quoi
ce n'est pas très étonnant
se retrouvent abandonnés très vite là
j'ai complètement raté l'ouverture et la
position est catastrophique
le roi est ouvert et le fou va jamais
rayonné d'un bébé trois genres fer droit
j'ai fait ce que je vais faire tous
rêvent sept de base
je veux faire tout rêve cette âme des
trois-tours f7 b1 qui avalise c4 ok ça
gagne un pion pour lui
sûrement à roye ouverte dit comme ça ça
fait pas rêver
il faut trouver du jeu
7 pour le moment autour c'est un serpent
6-6
j'ai bien rater dans l'ouverture mais ok
je vais essayer de faire un truc je fais
tout reprend m 23.9 le dam des quatre
oui bon ça plus jamais marcher
j'arrête de partout où je vais retour
est 100 premiers
ce qui est bien mauvais aussi
c'est foutu dit pas c'est foutu partout
raté l'ouverture
j'aurais dû jouer autrement
tu sais que mon roi il n'a pas de
cachette
ouais je vais me faire mater très
rapidement
c'est matt tout de suite je peux rien
faire ah je suis deg raté l'ouverture
j'ai vite été mal en fait bon fichier on
se fait dépouiller fait manger s'est
bien battu les mecs mais on perd 2 155
ha sans quoi non il est bon il était bon
il était bon on joue coude qu'il a
dimanche prochain adrian cham
taper avec un ton plus nette si rilov
bas ils sont bons et on a tout donné
sérieux sérieux on a tout fait pour
réussir est juste on n'a pas pu on a été
bon mais on n'a pas pu mais trop d'écart
peux-tu en faire un mail à jazz comme
après mais on n'a pas réussi à
ouais c'était dur commence ap deux best
il a perdu contre sharma de canal quoi
il doit le beauf est normalement un mec
comme ça elle va perdre le curage 5
c'est quand l'équipe de france c'était
maintenant c'est dommage des mecs demain
sera dernier stream sur bitstream avant
les candidats et après il y aura les
candidats mais aura quand même des
stream le soir pendant les candidats
avec fab à 20h30 pas tous les soirs mais
presque c'est quand même la grosse news
de la journée
c'est quand même la grosse info que je
vous lâche pas on s'est bien battu ans
quand même on s'est très bien battu
il y aura encore le rapide 10 plus de
vrai pour ceux qui veulent
pour moi ça s'arrêtera là
tu avais parti s'il vous prierais
parfois c'est un peu ça implique la qui
on va rester sur le direct et puis en
gardera peut-être ça demain
ben vous voyez pas la partie désolé
sur évident de pensa apprend le
classement enlevés
puisque je suis non non je suis pas
confier ce soir gerin qui a perdu six
matches mais ça arrive
ça c'est nul
le score c'est une viola d'art c'est la
viola da les amis on s'est fait violer
les amis on a été mauvais et la serbie
on a des chances adrian ou pas ils sont
encore plus fort que ça
pour s'est fait violer qu'est ce qu'il
fout [ __ ]
va la perdre
non ça fait mal mais toi aussi tu
travailles pas monsieur p soit
qui va se faire mater ça ça sent
pour marquer les mieux au temps mais de
façon le score est sans appel son est
tellement loin
l autre peut tomber c'était bien joué ça
avec la tour va faire ça et sur ces sept
ou huit tours prend 1,3
il n'a pas vu mais va perdre du cou ou
par wife 6-3 et 6-3 à être repensée set
ça doit encore aller quand on prend cet
essai nul
ça va il va la tenir s'est fait manger
devant au milieu encore pierre s'est
fait manger au milieu pantera fatahi ses
skis alors ils se bouffent l'eau ici
damas fin d'un rêve de ouais on s'est
fait manger les mecs
écoutez ça arrive hein c'est pas grave
basset avait fait un gros match et bien
démarré bastide a sorti le match ce soir
tu as été grand boss mais c'est d'amener
l'équipe derrière toi mais tu as pas
réussi à tout raciste on prend des six
tours f1 tout reprend airways 3 ou 4 le
rouscoff normalement il fait ça bon il
peut peut-être faire h4 intermédiaire
est ton point f6 pour apprendre 4es avec
un relief 5 à elle est rousse clubs sont
toujours des bonnes bonnes techniques
paris si tu prends une photo af 6 ça
semble assez puissant si ce rêve 2 3 3
non ce fait on se fait marcher dessus
bon le dernier match vous allez avoir
quoi commence dans dix minutes
bon j'espère que vous allez bien faire
les mecs
voilà les équipes donc si vous les jours
en dise plus de n'hésitez pas et c'est
de sauver ce qui est sauvable c'est
gagner un mini match c'est toujours ça
de pris
j'espère que vous êtes bien amusé et on
se retrouve demain du coup sûr bitstream
pour je ne sais pas quoi soit je ferai
des parties contre les débutants
puisqu'on verra plus grand chose pour
les débutants après soit je ferai des
blitz je sais pas mais en tout cas
c'était sympa et dernier truc qu'elle
joue dont je vais vous parler mais vu
qu'on a un peu nombreux encore ce soir
c'est
on va essayer de faire des matchs de
communautés en fait avec la communauté
bitstream contre d'autres cas contre
d'autres streamer je sais pas ça vaut
chauffe mais moi je pense que ça peut
être très très sympa on va essayer de
faire des matchs de communautés contre
compte d'escrimeur écho plus et on va
leur montrer la différence entre la
marque repère et l'écho plus et on
commencera peut-être peut-être par levi
roseman streamer new yorkais qui veut
qu'il veut réorganiser en france new
york
et si on fait un sport ans new york les
amis j'ai envie de vous dire
il faut il faut il faut il faut que vous
voulez des fonciers on va aller défoncer
c'est à dire qu'en cas de remariage
france new york je veux du sang sur les
murs les amis c'est à dire que ça va
bien se passer on va pas perdre de 192 à
115,6 ont refait un france ou ailleurs
je veux qu'on les explose je veux qu'on
ne les voie plus je veux qu'on leur dise
je vais à new york
je vais à new york pour que tu me casses
les jambes tu l'a écrit tu l'a écrit
dans tes dents tu es dans tes messages
et les captures écran je veux vraiment
qu'on l'ait qu'on les écrase
et je sais pas comment tout état partie
bosse je pas qu'on retrouve états
parties j'ai pas eu la partie basse le
match n'est plus en cour
sur mon profil attendu que je trouve ton
profil
mais comme tu es plus connectés ça va
être la galère c'est qu'aruna
je baille je baille j'arrive plus à
retrouver pas si longtemps parties ont
un truc que l'on trouve plus nathan
sylvain qui nous a envoyé une partie ça
peut être celle là a peut-être que ouais
tu vas henry tournoi merci du coup va
retrouver la partie charpentier
difficulté a été revue à le faire tomber
ces chemins séssion d'en arriver là
c'est tellement moche c'est tellement
moche c'est vous fait quel point ces
matches quand même et le tas a aucune
chance que c'est sûr qu'il va perdre ses
voudrait être arrivé à ce niveau là pour
faire ça ça me paraît toujours assez
incroyable a metz ils sont plus nettes
ça va ça allait pas du tout mais c'est
pas si mal mais ça va ça va ça va ok ça
va je sais pas pourquoi pas ramener plus
vite le roi quand même qu'à régler ces
quatre peut-être
ok
quelle affaire à 4 ans fait tout ça va
bien jusque là mais juste à 4 tu fixes
les pions et tu tapes à 3 tu as un
avantage tellement ce talent fait
jusqu'à vent c'était même plutôt bien
jouer quoi tu t'es bien organisée mais
tout d'un coup je passe que tu as fait
en fait
à quatre ça aurait été pas mal louette
avait la bonne structure de plants
avaient tous qu'en fait quand tu fais ça
et tu dois rester bien mais là ça
devient plus hachée ans a gagné parce
qu'il a pions pas s'éloigner à la faut
réussir à ramener le cavalier peut-être
qu'il y ait ici car il est ici qu il
s'essaie à une chance pour revenir en d6
comme ça tu as peut-être devenir un f5
il fait g4 qui est peut-être un coup
comme carillion 8,6 intéressant et moins
tu fais qu'un essai 7 tu colmatera cette
case là je rouspète important cas de f5
je peux faire ça ça et ça
probablement il peut pas rentrer parce
que tonton pur il avance et du coup tu
veux ki67 qui est prend 1,6 à
gagneraient donc l'un ou l'autre en fait
mais rend à 5 ça allait pas du tout mais
qui a été si ce qu'ils avaient vu qu'ils
essaient 7 et c'était tranquille quoi tu
que yelp y ont assisté tu gagner pour
les candidats du coup ça commencera
mardi à partir de midi sur la chaîne
chaise comme bien évidemment sur cette
même chaîne
on aura le soir les résumés
des parties de mv elle sur la chaîne
bitstream
et y'aura fable qui fera une petite et
sur la chaîne youtube blitz crime et y
aura fac qui fera une petite émission le
soir aussi à 20h30 sur bitstream twitch
du pouf
donc qu'est-ce qu'un fr pour l'émission
donc le twitter bitstream
il ya quand même beaucoup d'infos bon on
est tous sur twitter un toute façon je
vous souhaite à tous de rester en bonne
santé l'élite
faites attention à vous sortez si vous
en avez besoin
si on est obligé mais n'allez pas faire
les cons c'est important la santé de nos
anciens dépend de vous les amis donc
fait attention et a fait fait ce qu'il
faut a fait ce qu'il faut pour que pour
pas que nos anciens ou les personnes qui
ont des moyens militaires se retrouve en
danger
donc voilà même si vous pensez que pour
vous c'est pas grave et que et que ça va
penser aux autres
c'est pas une situation dans laquelle il
faut penser qu'à sa gueule et arrêter de
piller les magasins aussi parce que
c'est pas la guerre exactement tarbes
d'alter way ce que j'ai dit à monsieur p
soit les personnes constitution fragile
ce qui n'est pas immunitaire donc voilà
penser aux en tient à ces gens là et à
et comportez vous comme il se doit
montrer l'exemple et fait que ai fait
que dans quelques mois tout ça ne soit
qu'un mauvais souvenir
c'est le monde jeu collectif comme dit
sylvain exactement merci à tous en tout
cas et on se retrouve donc demain et
après après demain pour les candidats
c'est un plaisir de faire jouer ce match
avec vous contre la russie et dimanche
prochain ont défoncé